[Music]
since enumeration boom another one also
true wonderful to see all today but what
is certain is that aren't you will lift
the cup he gets his first title hey
welcome to Georgia voltage awake country
y'all to the adult porn in order to show
largely we get as far as you know
institution you can turn on the using
what little just flew
[Music]
in the decisive fashion around
Saoirse was a halogen moussaka Angela
vocals on bohon Road city huorchi lova
lova internal knowledge ready kuzey has
officially retired one of the legends of
the game one of the greatest players of
all time
League of Legends has lost an icon
LPL superstar uz has announced his
retirement after a long and successful
career but there's a catch
this guy is only 23 years old one of
league's greatest players is stepping
away from the game due to health issues
and injuries that have plagued him his
entire career so how did we get here
well mine you tend to win over fight any
other send [ __ ] Georgia to be sure to go
you'll be enjoyed her shortly Johan
don't find any or forgot all over to the
wrong position he found me anyway for
those of you who haven't kept up with
Uzis he's the epitome of excellence in
the world of ad carry's the gold
standard that everyone in his position
tries to achieve I think is retiring is
crazy this guy's literally the faker of
falling
he's so many that like I think everybody
care he looked up to when I played
against him I felt the most pressure in
lane I've ever felt my entire life like
it so they're like I can't breathe like
I felt like my mouse was like 100 pounds
is just he's just so good between his
laning mechanics team fighting and game
IQ it was he's the closest thing we've
seen to the perfect ad carry guerilla
going in aught to z tropic the attack by
the initiation
expert dog stay away as mink gets out as
well who's II was so good they're using
his ultimate ducks to skills huh and
getting away from everything and like I
said despite only being 23 years old
Lucy's had one of the longest careers in
League of Legends the do began competing
in 2012 at 15 and at 16 he made his
first World Championship finals starting
from the blue side for Dave one of this
best-of-five series with a season 3
World Championship record of five
regional tournament champions Royal Club
boozy quickly surpassed his
contemporaries becoming known as the
best ad carry even though others
challenged his title he also became the
most popular player in the LPL growing a
massive fan base around the world
you have many Western fans many who
think you are such a great ad carry is
there anything you would say to any of
those fans Oh Frank I see just Roman
offense anyway sister
Ronaldo kanji with a co-ed offense the
Colombian girl came over to clear cache
with awkward offensive in another scene
yet from Canada is a way to share that
piece I don't usually get I can call up
your channel but for years he was cursed
he was considered one of the best but
also considered one of the best to never
win dot the i's cross the t's RG set
themselves up to win the curse lifted
the purpose this be fulfilled
whose e now reigns
Royall never gives up champions and they
will take on the world
by 2018 was Susie's year he won his
first LPL title and spring followed that
up with a summer title and an Asian
Games gold medal months later but he did
more than that at MSI that year woozi
finally got the international title he
chased for so long
Rosie's been in the conversation of
greatest ADC for a very long time
although I think she finally got to
submit himself as the king of ADCs when
he picked up the LPL title he said that
he didn't just want his domestic title
that he wanted his international one and
with that I think you need to start
having the conversation of possibly
greatest player of all time there's no
questioning Ozzy's greatness with both
domestic and international titles under
his belt he's a living legend whose
level of success few others will ever
obtain but it came at a cost
yo Justin you 9/10 I'm one of the you
should go just flush it say that's cool
I didn't even point out throughout his
entire career goosies battled injuries
it seemed like every other split he was
taking a break in order to maintain his
health I have to remind everyone that
for today's matchups it will not be uz
playing would actually be weak complaint
a new player they brought up from the
LCL to suck it now nothing to be aware
of nothing to be super worried about
hoozy is healthy but he typically does
take breaks before Chinese New Year for
many players especially the game's
longtime veterans these sorts of
physical health problems come from the
rigorous lifestyle most pros have to
deal with the geo - from a
community-based officer - refrigerated
food again which made him Tony end up
being was a - in there but Busey always
returned from his breaks looking like
the best ad carry in the world
dazzling people with his skills and
making them forget that he ever took a
break in the first place
alright yesterday yeah
very saucy take a holiday
mmm social was a holiday in LA
during why it's a controllable quote
humble and old city [ __ ] should all
have answered you know what that you
idiot
wrapped with health issues that continue
to get worse under his pro-player
lifestyle boozy retired at 23 years old
in addition to his shoulder and wrist
issues Busey revealed in his June 3rd
announcement that he'd been diagnosed
with diabetes person geophone me a fine
gentleman
careful huh cause without you know what
sure you autonomy or there's a high end
while there to enjoy sense that you've
wolf in the gang in your scene whichever
by watching a Austria now I wish what a
[ __ ] harmed way Busey is leaving as one
of the game's greats his legacy will be
near impossible for any future ad
carried to match from becoming the first
back-to-back world finalist at the ages
of 16 and 17 to his LPL MSI rift rivals
in the Asian Games titles Busey retires
with an untouchable legacy to his name
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages